[Music]
this is so
exciting live concerts are finally
coming back and it was an emotional
return to the stage for miranda lambert
the grammy winner performed her first
socially distanced in-person show in
over a year since the kobit 19 pandemic
began last march
hitting the stage at billy bob's texas
in her home state
miranda was overcome with emotion when
she performed her massive hit
the house that built me
[Music]
happy
[Music]
oh i still love that song so much and
that just gave me chills i mean i loved
hearing all the fans cheering her on and
shouting at the lyrics to back her up
and being on stage right outside of her
hometown wasn't enough i can only
imagine
how emotional it was to sing that song
in the first place
of course she looked absolutely
incredible on stage wearing a classic
country glam ensemble in a black mini
skirt
paired with a western shirt with white
fringe a chunky belt and white
cowboy boots she also took to twitter
after the show
writing we're back y'all we did our
first three shows
back at billy bob's texas last weekend
and had a blast
thanks to everyone who came out the warm
welcome back to the stage with the band
after 400 plus days sure felt good
loved getting back to my old stomping
grounds see y'all next weekend
yeah miranda enjoyed a three-night sold
out stint at billy bob's
and we'll be back for additional shows
this coming weekend
and on may 7th miranda will release her
latest project
the marfa tapes with collaborators jack
ingram and john randall